[Music]
samuel leeds is britain's most notorious
multi-millionaire property investor
best-selling author and founder of a
leading property education company
with hundreds of success students
carving their way to financial freedom
using his cutting-edge strategies
samuel is regarded as the ultimate
renegade property investor
in this year's eviction the stakes have
been raised big time
with the winner receiving the keys to
the kingdom by getting a life-changing
prize
of a whole week's one-to-one mentoring
in their own
financial freedom challenge more drama
more heartbreak and more action as
candidates battle it out to be the 2020
winner of
the eviction we had over 500 people
applied to be on the eviction
we've got 10 candidates that are part of
the process
let's see what happens this is crazy
you're evicted
hi my name is lawson hopwood and i'm a
senior account manager from manchester
my name is david eckles i'm from ireland
i want you to find and be prepared to
present
maybe to me maybe to the room your brr
deal you do realize that the property
has sold
well it's going to be very tough working
together so you're evicted dude with
regret you're evicted
so what do you think i'm gonna say now
you're evicted
i'm stressed i'm stressed on their
behalf
i'm confident we're gonna win you've got
till then to sell that deal
i would recommend you sell it tonight
and you get the money in your bank
tonight i've just secured a deal in
warrington
tonight's gonna be hard two minutes to
go why why prolong the sale
tonight yeah and some of them already in
interest that's huge
we haven't got the anger that we got
strong team
i don't know who's gonna win this this
could go either which way so
i'm very sorry but you're evicted
after samuel kicked out a few no hopers
in the last episode we're back with a
deal selling challenge
certain to blow the socks off the
remaining candidates and sort the
dreamers from the doers
with laptops and teeny tiny cups of
coffee at the ready
let's join samuel to see what's in store
as our candidates move one step closer
to their financial freedom challenge
no pulling pulling no punches hard
core tonight is not going to be easy
tonight's going to be
hard i think what howard she's going to
roll is i'm going to give you what i'm
going to give you the challenge now
but i don't want you to start doing your
challenge until 6 00 p.m
because believe me from now until 6 pm
so this is about deal selling so i'm
going to give you your challenge shortly
there are going to be people throughout
the whole night who are going to help
you with
your challenge you're going to be
working in teams it's not just going to
be me helping you out you're also going
to have some of my associates that are
going to help you out the previous
candidates of the eviction so we've got
james armstrong
james armstrong as far as deal selling
is concerned has sold
tens of thousands of pounds worth of
deals he's going to be training you
mentally last year when i was in the
eviction i went out at round
three and i was gutted i was so good but
at the same time look
18 months later i'm making really really
good money on property we made 50 grand
this month from deal sourcing
the same deals that they're trying to
sell in there right there so we know
that they make money the strategies work
the education works the same training
that they've had to do all this is the
same training that i've used to get to
where i am now and for those people who
get evicted it's not the end of the road
you know
even the deals today if you don't sold
you can still sell them tomorrow or the
next week and you can still make money
from that
anthony wilmar winner of last year's
eviction guys hi my name is anthony
wilmott and i was the winner of the 2019
eviction
so i've come along today just to give
some coaching advice to the current
contestants
and i don't think they really realize
how much they're going to grow and learn
from this process
hannah mills who i've not seen in far
too so my name's hannah mills
i took part in the very first eviction
in the castle uh i came second
to anthony although um he's currently
cheering in the background right now i
still hate him a little bit
um but at the moment i deal sauce mainly
and the eviction
basically taught me how to deal source i
learned a hell of a lot out of everyone
that was there
and i'm excited for these guys and the
process that they're gonna go for in the
journey because uh
if it's anything like mine um then
they're gonna love it
and ricky ricky was the guy that was he
was a vic
hey what's up everyone i'm ricky i was
on the 2019 eviction
and to be fair i started off as the
laughing stock of the eviction
uh you know it was embarrassing to begin
with but i've learned so much and i've
grown up as a person
as a businessman and i have a dual
sourcing business we do rent to rent
i'm also working on developments but the
biggest thing i took away from the 2019
eviction
was how much work you can actually get
done when the pressure's on how this is
going to roll is you're going to sell a
deal
when the ducks aren't all in a row
because if the deal falls through or
there's problems
guess what they have a 14 day calling
period so it's just about getting the
money selling the deal
alistair is going to talk very briefly
about
everything you need to know a to z of
how to close because the biggest part of
deal selling is in the name it's it's
selling
it's selling you got through the first
round
which means you know how to find deals
you've done the buy refurbished
refinance master class
so you know how to find deals you know
how to present deals
because you presented deals to me and
you all did really well and if you
hadn't done well guess where you'd have
been
evicted so you can find deals you can
package them
you can present them the thing you're
going to need to learn about now which
alistair is going to help you with
is closing a deal because here's what's
going to happen when you try and set a
deal okay this is going to happen the
deal looks great but can i view it first
of course you can view it of course you
can view it listen
what do you need to know from me right
now in order to make an informed
decision
uh lawton lawton give lauren a hand to
vehicle michael all right coming up
i want to take really really really good
notes
not just of what's happening but most
importantly of the actual deal
if you've got a smartphone get get the
property up now
you can be looking at it seeing what's
happening i'm going to do that right now
now when you're actually selling it to a
real investor
you will only you will only let them see
it if they sign a non-disclosure
agreement first
if they don't sign a non-disclosure
agreement first you can't give them
stuff like the postcode you know why
because they'll just put it in rightmove
and they'll find it
okay so you're going to sell this deal
to me um
hey lawson i just saw this property you
said it's worth one two five
it's on you've got it for 85. i'm really
interested
so i'm going to send you over an mda
you're going to send that back over to
me
i wouldn't do i wouldn't mess around
with that so
let me tell you why though let me tell
you why i probably wouldn't mess around
with that
because time is money so i'll just be
like
have you got the money in the bank are
you ready to go
great it's worth one two five it's on
the market
i've got it for eight five what else do
you need to know
find out what they need to know answer
their questions
all right great so if you ping me 2 000
pounds
and then i'll send you all the details
and you'll have 14 days to do your due
diligence any problems
and if the property is not what i said
i'll refund you that gives you 14 days
then to wrap everything up
if you send them an nda then what will
happen is in their minds
oh i'll have to sign it i'll sign it
tomorrow
and then i'll do my due diligence forget
that
you need the money in the bank
why prolong the sale
hey i just saw the property you said you
got it for 85 it's worth 125.
i'm interested could you give me some
more details what else do you need to
know today to make an informed decision
oh well um what would the rent be the
rent would be approximately between
750 and 800 a month sounds pretty good
yeah sounds pretty good
um and what kind of area is it in
warrington all right
would you be able to send me over the
address and and all the market research
that you've done
yes great here's my email send it over
that's now that's not going to take
the informed days back to the you ask
the questions
if they say to you if they say to you oh
um could you send me some more details
sure but what could i possibly email
that i couldn't tell you right now what
do you need to know from me
so you've got a legitimate deal one two
five
that you found from the buyer
refurbished refinance master class and
you've got it for 85 grand
right the rent is how much
750 a month decent area in warrington
you guys have got the postcode the
refurb
cost that's needed on it is a budget
25 grand and the new value is
between 135 and 140 135 and 140.
the fact that you found that deal makes
you automatically a team leader for the
next challenge
who's going to be the next team leader
all right david coming up
who you want on your team all right
coming out come on up
oh sorry team of three team of four okay
here's the next challenge you all know
about this deal
you gotta sell the deal okay now i know
it's your deal
i get that you found it okay so
so so if you guys sell the deal you're
gonna get half the fee
okay because they if they sell it now of
course the deal
only only half exists because you've not
actually had a proper
secured offer but what did i tell you
about an hour ago you don't need it
you don't need it if you sell the deal
and you get two grand in your bank
and then it ends up the deal falls
through does it matter no you refund the
investor so sorry it didn't work out but
then you've done it you've done it
okay so you've got to sell the deal you
know all the figures you've got the
right move link
and we're going to have a meeting
tomorrow at 12 p.m
and by 12 p.m tomorrow one team
is going to have sold the deal if you've
both sold the deal great
who sold it for a higher amount we need
the money in a bank
needs to be physically in a bank you're
going to find your own investors
if you're struggling the mentors will
help you out
tomorrow we're going to have a boardroom
meeting and we're going to look at which
team did best
of the losing team there's going to be
at least one eviction
any questions so 12 o'clock tomorrow at
my house
we're going to be meeting and you've got
till then to sell that deal i would
recommend you sell it tonight and you
get the money in your bank tonight
so the teams have until midday tomorrow
to sell the deal that the incredible
hulk found with samuel's aides offering
a helping hand and using all of their
training the teams are aiming to sell
the deal to an investor and have the
money in the bank before going to
samuel's house for a brew tomorrow
afternoon literally just come out of
there at the room of the challenge and
the guys are basically trying to find
investors and sell a deal and one of the
things i literally cannot
hammer into them enough is the fact that
a lot of them have really big social
media presences
and yet they haven't even thought about
selling their deal on social media
it's now seven o'clock at night and
they're thinking about how
they can basically email and they can
bring their lists get it on social media
get it out there and then ring the list
because they can reach so much more of a
presence
and so that's one of the things that
i've tried to tell them so just been
role-playing with some of the
contestants
and i'm not really sure some of them are
going to sell the deal because they're
trying to answer every single question
that an investor is going to ask them
and they're going to end up selling
themselves out of the deal you need to
get to the point
find out what the investor wants and
then close them on the deal
so i'm walking around speaking to people
seeing how they're getting on and the
pressure is on
i can feel the heat in here everyone's
just running around they're on the phone
they're talking they're speaking with
investors
i spoke to the group of three and i said
to them how many investors have you
called and they said three
i said great what's happening with them
they're gonna let us know no worries if
you've got any more to ring they said
yeah
yeah get on the phone to him you haven't
sold the deal yet
it's not been sold until you've seen the
gold get ringing the other investor
because
you can't rely on the other investors
and the pressure is on when the
pressure's on
ring investors get it sold and don't
settle until you've seen the gold that's
my biggest tip for them um what are you
guys thinking
what do you think who's gonna win how
strong are the contestants was i too
harsh
what's happening i think they're too
slow taking action i took time to do
that i don't think they're too slow
if james really had made 50 grand in the
last month he'd thought he'd been able
to afford a pair of trousers that come
with fabric for his knees
and they're focusing on the wrong thing
yeah you had a conversation with them
they're worried about
the floor plan yeah you know like get
the figures down and get it out to the
investor
i think what is interesting because you
take to when we were doing this 18
months ago and i remember like when we
were
sorting everything we were so worried
about certain aspects of the deal
and literally when we got in front of
the investors all they cared about was
the figures
and like obviously as we've all sort of
deal sourced and sold things
all we do is talk about the figures and
that's it and then we close whereas
these guys like you said
oh we need to get the floor plans we
need to get an nda no you don't need to
get an nda you just need to get on the
phone you need to get the deal out there
and i think that's
that's one thing that they're probably
quite daunting that's it all comes back
to that point of
understanding your investors yeah you
know they've got some great investors
they're going to get on the phone with
and have a chat with
so they haven't asked them what types of
deals they're interested in yeah which
you know they're going to jump on the
phone and start reaming out loads and
loads and loads and loads of stuff about
the deal
without even knowing what that
investor's interested in yeah i think
there's a lot of um
just from what i heard i think there's a
lot of waffling going on as well yeah
you know
from people just aren't answering
straight questions no they're not honest
like someone where's your where's your
yeah me yeah of course i
admit i on the first of it but i learned
from it
and now i know when you speak to an
investor on the phone you're going to
sort of real deal
if you waffle they're not interested and
i said to one group then where'd you
find your investor from
well you know we we've started here and
i certainly in business just get
straight to the point
where did you find this investor then
just and i think that's going to be a
problem for a lot of people on here it's
going to happen
i think this pressure is going to be
really good for them and i think this is
going to
already the conversations that we've had
with them you're going to start to pick
out the people that are going to be
the top they'll take it off to take it
on board if i were you
i'd go swimming it's not getting easier
on them and it's not about
no no because you're because your best
experience
there's definitely an element of that
but no idea to be fair james i was
pretty hard on you when you had a
ridiculous ponytail that made you look
like a sick unicorn
no you don't learn from learn from love
that's really philosophical that is well
that's true
from love if you put yourself in their
position
where they're just starting out on
property not done any real advanced
training and they've just been told
they've got several doing a night
and some of them already in interest
that's huge
that's the dinner and like imagine how
much
sense of achievement they're gonna get
tomorrow morning when they wake up and
sold an amazing deal to an investor
they've got a great relationship with
because they've asked the right
questions hi guys what's going on
when that's there it's like something
else hey guys i've got oh [ __ ]
about the fact that it's a property so
i've just secured a property because
it's a great deal i don't know what that
means i've just secured a property for
85 grand
i'll just keep it i know the end value
will be 135 but i just say
it's worth one two five okay
how many how many people do you have
following you generally every person has
like 2 000 friends
if you post that there's only one person
to see and go
that's all right yeah bang you made two
two three read how much you could sell
it
your money's in your list yes that's
right
good social distance in there lads well
we spoke to
uh the landlord directly so everything
that we tell you is actually being
tested
we spoke to him he's currently in in a
sticky situation because of corvid and a
lot of
you know personal things um but he has
agreed for cash buyer to get it for 85
000 pounds
okay well we would be a cash bar so
that's fine absolutely
so just you know just to make obviously
you know you know save your time and
stuff what do we have to say or what
what do we have to do tonight
to secure your business
cool so if we send you an nd across um
within the next few minutes can you get
it signed
if it was to meet the requirements and
everything that we've already told you
would you be in a position to send a
deposit today tonight and
if it was to wasn't to meet what we've
told you then you can
get a refund if it wasn't correct
yeah yeah okay fantastic okay so let's
do this
let's uh if you can obviously just text
files over your email we'll ping
everything over to the nda
you can sign in online and we'll send
everything that you need and from now
till tomorrow you speak to your jv
partner and we can get on the phone
tomorrow after seven and then
um close the door yeah
sounds great um to have
photographs
cool so we'll give you everything that
we have um after you sign the nda
and you can always say to your due
diligence um based on that
okay all right thank you julie cool yeah
thank you so much
cheers let's meet you tomorrow
okay well i've got someone who's willing
great job guys looking promising
four thousand pound figures well that's
steep
when you
good strong team strong team
i don't know who's going to win this
this could go either which way but
tomorrow someone
will be a victim who lives in a house
like this
samuel leads actually
when it comes to putting money in the
bank being very difficult so
that's what i am right now i'm trying to
close the still man
it's not opening it's just not coming
on the phone yeah but by telling like
another investor that that deal sword
and he's just seen it yeah it shows how
quickly
there can be a turnaround yeah yeah and
like what alastair always says is like
train your investors you don't know that
you call the shots
yeah the two-bed terrace house um it's
in need of a full reverb
just checking his tender profile we've
literally got an
hour so you'd have to do that um after
two years if you're gonna do it on a
two-year fix but with
for this kind of property deal i would
suggest going through either cash is in
cash or bridging
last night was crazy um myself
jayden lawton we actually didn't have
that many investors
within our access but what we did is we
said that the ones that we actually do
have
um we're gonna call them up and just see
what they've got and
you know what it is it is in our list
that we've managed to
um secure a deal we managed to secure
that yesterday at around 11 p.m
but at the moment now we are um going
again
and seeing if we can secure another one
our one of our problems is is that
we are actually creating our list as
we're going on we
didn't have a list where the other team
might have already had this i believe he
did absolutely
like 250 people so he's got a phone
number so he's ringing why don't you
stop falling asleep
we'll focus on what you've got lawson
keeps complaining about
there's no one with a list but here's
the thing he chose his teammates
i mean endrit who's on the other team
prior said
i've got a list of lots of people he
could have chose him you got to take
complete responsibility you chose your
teammates
you found the deal come on please
just get in touch all right
this morning were very confident they
were going to win they thought they had
it in the bag they had the money
however when i told them that actually
david's team now have just sold a deal
now and david's sold their deal for a
little higher fee
so david's team are in the lead
similarly the whole of lawton's room
the energy is flat i think they know
they're going to fail
i think that they know they're going to
struggle to get another deal they're sat
there
they're looking at their phones they're
waiting for the phone to ring you can't
wait for the phone to ring
you got to pick up the phone and you've
got to be phoning investors the
david's room they're all on the phone
they've got high energy
i think i think i think that lawson's
team have given up
the energy sucks i can't even be in the
room right now the energy is so
low and where energy is low success and
money
is also low so i think they've given up
on themselves
so we'll see what happens
there we go two minutes i couldn't i
could have had money in the bank man
how did you not do that microsoft word
bro
because i'm old school i think they're
never beers man they cannot art
us i don't care who they have what this
their deal they haven't got the hunger
that we got yeah we have to win that
no doubt since alastair told them that
they needed to increase their energy
they've all disappeared and now they're
walking around that's the thing you've
got to be up
standing on the phone so there's they're
selling more deals they're bringing
money in
the only problem is david's team i've
also just got some more money
so it's going to be really close the
time we've now only got
20 minutes left i don't know what's
going to happen but they've both done
extremely well
did you get that agreement i sent you
yeah yeah right i'm going to send it to
this guy as well and try and get 500.
so i mean i said 3k but he was
negotiating it down
so it don't matter we need it
it doesn't matter we need it yeah a deal
is a deal well done
literally the deal is in your list
because i had a contact
who knew another contact it wasn't him
he knew another contact and that person
um has literally called me they said
they were going to call me since 9am
it's now 11am i've got the call in and
they have agreed to send 2k so we're
just waiting for that to get started
we've got no total
5700. what good i'm looking to get
another 500 pounds hopefully that comes
in before 12 o'clock and i've got
another investor who's interested in the
actual deal okay sometime talking to me
then get on the phone
come on fingers crossed
who else thinks
[Music]
party on our deal however i really need
to push you
for a phone call before 12 o'clock
ideally i actually need an answer before
tough muck i have another investor who's
ready to pay the money
and get this deal boxed off at 12. and
i'm actually out and away from my office
or my home office
but i can get the contract sent over to
you if you can get that money
sent over by 12 weekly security and i
can get the picture sent over to you
later today
is there anything else he needs from me
to make an informed choice as the
countdown ticks down to 12 o'clock
both teams are making one final push to
sell their deals so they can enter the
boardroom with as much money in the bank
as possible
the winners are the team who've made the
most money during the challenge
and of the losing team two minutes to go
at least one candidate will be evicted
it's not gonna be us we're gonna win
come on i'm a hat i'm confident we're
gonna win
okay just because it's got one minute
until the deadline
we've got another investor who's ready
to pop that money in thank you so much
speak to you soon i'm stressed i'm
stressed on their behalf
deadlines past deals secured but who
is out of time in the boardroom
[Music]
welcome to the eviction uh you've all
done pretty well
how did it how did it go i feel like it
went very successful
definitely well you both sold deals
which is pretty good although
if i'm totally honest you guys sold
a couple of deals which is great um
although i've just been thinking about
this because you you found both
investors david
yeah and you sold the two deals
yeah so what did you guys do
well we've won many investors um i was
on the phone to overturn investors
i heard you on the phone to a lot of
investors as well but
what i'm thinking is you sold two deals
both of them were david's investors
and david sold both of the deals
and right now i'm having to evict people
so
i'm just trying to yeah apart from
speaking to investors
like what did what did like fans what
did you actually contribute to this to
this exercise
i did find one of the hottest leads we
had throughout the whole
time and did they did the hottie bye
okay so what did you actually contribute
to this challenge
um just i think as much as anyone else
obviously got the deals
but i was trying to ring as many
investors as i can i never had an
invested list
but i still try and put ourselves out
there and you said that many times
i keep hearing it over and over from
fast i haven't got an investor list i
haven't got an investor list yeah i'm
like anthony how's it going
well faz told me he doesn't have an
investor list alastair what's happening
well faz told me he doesn't have an
investor list
why do you keep saying it no one doesn't
invest in this no one cares
i didn't make the most of my situation
but you didn't bring one deal to the
table you didn't find bring one investor
to the table that bought you didn't sell
anything
what did you actually do our highest
lead but the hottest person didn't buy
i understand that but from not having a
list and everyone else calling there
again yeah dude you keep telling me you
don't have a list
do you know what like do you know what i
hear when you say that i hear an excuse
i feel i made my own i
use this competition i made my own list
and i was calling them and i built good
relationships
that will last and i can now find other
deals that made
my clothes on okay andrew what did you
bring to the table because again same
story
you didn't sell anything and none of
your investors bought
i spoke to many investors and constantly
i was keeping the team up
i was um these investors are
they you're keeping the team up with the
energy up were yeah
so did you did you feel that was he
keeping the energy up
uh you had a pad to play in it yeah okay
yeah and i was those i've had two
investors who i've sent terms and
conditions to
who said they would put the money in
yeah i didn't get it in time
but i've got i've built um strong
investors who
are willing to invest and with future
projects that come on
okay okay and i heard you on the phone
um
evan's quite a lot you were definitely
active on the phone calls
but you didn't sell anything right why
is that
um i just don't think
i had enough time i'm being i'm not
making any excuses i had somebody who
was obviously david had enough time
because he sold two deals
yeah so why did david have enough time
but you didn't have enough time
i think david definitely had more
training in in deal sourcing
and brr i'm known to my network as a
rental renter so it's the first time
i'm speaking up about investing in
anything um but i have got two people
that i was obviously keen to go
and i'm adamant if i had half an hour
more over the line
yeah david do you reckon you'd have been
able to do what you did
you found the investors you sold the
deals you found the deals
just on your own
yeah possibly so what does that say
about your team
well the team like were really good yeah
the energy was great
you wouldn't have had the the dances and
the cheering without the team but
unfortunately dancing and cheering
doesn't bring any money in and if you'd
have done that on your own without the
team
then why shouldn't i just evict the
whole team apart from you
because realistically david really had
an example set by him yesterday
i go on the phone yesterday i spoke to
investors i actually set the example
prior to yesterday i didn't sell
anything david is the only one who saw
something but if david didn't see what i
did he wouldn't
emulate the same thing today and get the
results that he did
okay so you guys um you also sold
well you sold you sold two two and a
half deals you sold two deals and you
had a bespoke
person come on um i think you would
do more if you didn't have that one hour
dip of energy where you're all just sat
on your phone
refreshing the page getting upset
listening to these guys cheering
um i think you would have done better so
what happened yeah i definitely feel
like we
felt you know demotivated when we heard
them cheering and we did have a dry
spell
but when you've got 12 hours you can't
afford to have a dry spell
you know unless it's a few hours when
you're sleeping like it's it's it's it's
10 o'clock on a monday morning
hot and you guys would just sat around
for about an hour and a half and i think
that
i think that let you down a bit uh apart
from that you all sold a deal
you all contributed to the challenge so
at least one person is going to be
evicted and it is going to be the person
from the losing team
so you sold in total
five thousand seven hundred pounds
you guys sold over eight thousand pounds
so you are the winning team
i think mostly because of david
but uh you're the winning team so you
guys are safe
you can go back through to the lounge
enjoy have some champagne off you go
yeah well you're all through to the next
good good round effort we've got to hook
it up
okay we've got a huge it's a responsible
i don't know like the top responsibility
you know it's i know it's early the
finger's going to be pointed to team
leader but the guys you're
no you you did really well now they're
really welcome i had to put the pressure
on a little bit but you didn't
thank you great they're all there
wow
okay so unfortunately one person's
at least is going to be evicted today uh
you lost the challenge
you sold less than the other team you
were
team leader so ultimately
i guess it lies on you i mean do you
think do you think that you were
responsible for that
that 90-minute glitch that happened no i
don't think i was personally responsible
for that and i feel like that
sort of downtime was a time when we was
looking and getting uh phone calls
booked in
we was all speaking to investors through
messenger because all these came through
facebook yeah
i mean all of them our entire list has
grown over facebook yeah
and we was using messenger to speak to
them and book them calls in so when you
guys came in
okay so we felt deflated for sure yeah
so if you were me now then having to
evict one person at least who would you
evict
if i was you i'd probably be a bit the
person who contributed
and who's that unfortunately i do feel
like it was you that contributed to
these just because of the
pound sign we all brought inside we all
worked collectively as a team
yeah brilliantly okay so
so you think that jayden should be
evicted yes
yeah so jaden you're in a really sticky
situation
but i personally think i had a high
amount of calls
i put in a load of effort i don't
believe in my ability i show up
i showed up hour early today for the
class i didn't get
so i sold the deal for 100 pounds or
sold the um
bespoke saucing off of 100 pounds yeah
but i show up
the training yesterday i show up i still
have shotguns that i've done and show up
as i've done i'll show up no one's no
one's saying you you no one's saying you
did bad
yeah but we've got to evict somebody
so so so listen listen so jaden
who do you think i should evict i think
you should make it oh yeah
why do you think that because i think
that even yesterday she was late to the
um
she was late to turn up and i think that
even though she sold her
for two thousand pounds that that was
gonna come
comes down to a bit of luck as well
because she had appreciated a good lead
but in the other day i think i worked
that much harder than i put in
more effort like literally like 10 100
more effort
than she was she did it's a tough one
because because
jaden has clearly got a lot of energy
and
and he does show up and his energy has
been great
uh do you think he's gonna go real far
so so jaden
oyen's found somebody from scratch
pulled in two thousand pounds on the
challenge
you've done great you poured in 100
pounds
but it's gonna be tricky for me to evict
oyen
when when she did better than you hey
then you you're a great candidate
you're going to go very far we're going
to continue to do business with you but
unfortunately
you did bring the least to the to the
table so
i'm very sorry but you're evicted thanks
opportunity
can i say something jayden's been
evicted out of the house however jayden
if you are willing and available as from
tomorrow
we're running a two-day rent-to-rent
training with alastair
it's it's a two and a half thousand
pound program
i'd like to gift you that yeah i
definitely yeah so
so alistair will will take you through
that but i do believe in you as a person
i do want to stay in touch i want to get
you on the academy or something like
that
um but you and you did really well yeah
so i know you're evicted because you
know what everyone here is a very strong
contestant however for the next couple
of days you're going to be trained with
air
we're going to train you through rent to
rent and um know that you'll be on
windows wednesday next time you're here
also yeah definitely
i'm obviously disappointed i'm going to
make excuses i see that i sold the lease
on my deals hold it for
the bespoke source enough for 100 pounds
someone but
the point is yeah i saw the least oyena
and lawton
props to them they sold it for three
thousand six hundred and
two thousand so end of the day i saw
this my deal was what that's life
i'm still gonna go on to be successful
and do more things
here i'm gonna be on a winners wednesday
one day as well let's say three months
from now so
what experience in general has been
amazing that it's actually been crazy
i've learned so much from the past two
days i've been here that
it's actually nuts how much do i mean
when you set a deadline when you set a
time limit when you just
take action the higher amounts of energy
and actually get yourself done and stop
procrastinating do i mean
there's no time for slacking you just
gotta keep at it and yeah i've learned
so much from alex there
from people like james armstrong people
like samuel um
anthony just been even off camera just
educating us giving us more tips more
more things to say to investors in order
to get the deal done and stuff like that
so i'm gonna go home
go away and put what i've learned in
action
and actually get my own deals as well
and be successful coming up tomorrow
we've got
50 hours they don't really know what
they're doing two dollars from postcodes
that's awesome because i'll pack up and
go home like i know i will because it
doesn't bother me you're gonna present
to me
and show me the lease option agreement
contract signed yes
yes it is well done that just came out
of nowhere
honestly not even one of them can close
the door you've secured
during the challenge of course marriage
we were separated at the start and then
we've come together and united i feel
like a bromance